[Music]
honduras it's
one of the most dangerous places in the
world to be environmental activists
the case of better casseroys is
emblematic it's a microcosm of the
situation in honduras for many activists
and defenders
berta caceres one of the country's most
well-known indigenous environmental
leaders
was gunned down in home early thursday
less than a year after she won
the prestigious goldman environmental
prize
[Music]
this particular murder was particularly
brazen
someone thought that they could murder
a very very prominent person that they
would be able to get away with that
this is a story that i had been
following
since the actual murder in 2016.
and as i followed it over the years the
investigation evolved it kept taking
different twists and turns
there is no evidence whatsoever that
could link me to the killing alberta
okay
so
[Music]
[Music]
a
[Music]
berti casares was born into a very
political family
a family of activists really her mother
was
one of the first female mayors in
honduras she was the mayor of a town
called la esperanza
para nosotros nosotros
[Music]
um
[Music]
she was raised a catholic she was not
raised in a traditionally indigenous
household
but by the time she reached her 20s she
identified as a linka woman that's the
biggest indigenous group
native to honduras somos custodios
ancestrales
nuestras cosmo viciones
[Music]
she co-founded a human rights
organization called copen
that was basically for indigenous
communities in honduras
and so by her 30s she was a national
leader
she was someone who was extremely
passionate about
the rights of the downtrodden the
marginalized indigenous
in her country she was also very amber
very pleasant very friendly
she was good fun but behind the kind of
laughter the smiles
you knew that she had a steely call this
is
angry protesters at the doorsteps of
honduras presidential palace want
president manuel celia back
there was a coup in honduras in 2009
and the government that took over really
put
development as one of the main
priorities for the country
and with that came this big building
boom
honduras does not produce many natural
resources that can be used for energy
but one thing that it does have is a lot
of rivers
so you had a lot of hydroelectric dams
that suddenly were slated
for areas where there was very little
development
one of these companies that formed at
this time was called dessa
and its sole purpose was to develop the
agua zarka dam
in western honduras you had
international development banks
funding it along with private investment
in honduras
and berta caceres heard about this
project
knew that there was a link a community
that lived nearby
and she really sort of led an opposition
movement
the residents worried that the dam
project would
flood out the areas that were critical
for them to grow
staples like corn and coffee but even
more than that
they argued that the river itself was
sacred
and that to damn it in this way was a
violation
of lincoln tradition
usted
[Applause]
residents began staging protests doing
things like
creating roadblocks they would stack
stones on the roads so
construction equipment could not reach
the work site
if you talk to dessa the hydroelectric
company
they will say that the majority of
people in the communities living around
the river
supported the project this is a point of
contention
they argue that the community was in
support of the dam
although there were protests and marches
going on at the same time
[Applause]
decided this is a project that it would
move forward with without consultation
with local communities
and there has been just a tremendous
amount
of bloodshed and violence
on july 15 2013 there was a spontaneous
impromptu rally at the desa worksite
and this is a date that everybody on
both sides
of this conflict remembers very well
tomas garcia who was a coping protester
was among a crowd who entered the desa
worksite
and one of the guards a security guard
shot and killed tomas and shot and
wounded his son
alan
right after the violence happened desa's
contractor
ceno hydro pulled out of the project
they abandoned
the work site and they never came back
[Music]
territorial
instead of abandoning the project they
actually redesigned it
so they moved the site of the dam two
kilometers upriver
and they also downsized it to be a
what's called a run-of-the-river project
so there's less impact to the
environment but as the protesters
contended
there's not zero impact so they have
their first public protest
against the dam in its new location in
november
of 2015 and that's when we think
that plans to murder berta
really began to materialize
she would tell a lot of her friends that
she would be getting
threats from people at desa
you better watch out watch your back she
reported cars
following her on the roads
you know she would often look look
behind her shoulder
um she had people who would help her
with with security
she was definitely scared she knew she
was she was at risk
[Music]
of
to
in 2015 she won the goldman prize
which is sometimes called the green
nobel it's really the biggest prize
an environmental activist can get and it
really kind of
pushed her up into a different level of
notoriety
[Applause]
with hindsight maybe we could say that
the golden prize put at greater risk
it's something that is we need to
grapple with as international
you know human rights community whether
we think that it's a deterrent effect
to be able to raise someone's profile in
the media or if that
puts them at greater risk it's very hard
to say
the request
the prize also came with 175
dollars as a cash award and so berta
went back to honduras and a lot of that
money she poured into coping
into new projects and new facilities in
la esperanza
in march of 2016 she had actually put
together a workshop
in la esperanza and one of the people
who was speaking at this workshop
was named gustavo castro he's an
environmentalist from mexico
he was planning on staying at another
house with someone else in la esperanza
and he went out to visit berta and saw
how
isolated her house was
[Music]
this house was located on the outskirts
of la esperanza on the far edge of town
and they started chatting and she ended
up inviting him to stay
in her guest bedroom
[Music]
gustavo was in his room in the guest
bedroom and berta was down the hall
and gustavo heard a noise in the kitchen
before he could even leave the room to
check things out
he heard the bangs there were gunshots
coming from berta's room
the gunman apparently thought that he
was dead and left
and after he heard the gunman leave the
house
he got up and checked on baritone
me
gustavo searched around for a telephone
found berta's phone
and just started calling everybody on
her contacts
when he eventually did contact people
friends of bertas they advised him not
to call the police
i think it's safe to say that oftentimes
the police were part of the problem
not part of the solution there are
terrible stories of the police hierarchy
being involved in murder for hire
schemes
if you called the police they may be as
likely to shake you down
as they were to help you so
friends of bertas helped get him to
another house
and the police when they did arrive they
found
his suitcase in the spare bedroom and so
the police identified him as a suspect
but pretty much everyone who was close
to berta
simply assumed that this had something
to do
with her opposition to the damn project
[Music]
it was a complete shock it was a shock
but at the same time
i wasn't surprised if that makes sense
because of the people that she was
fighting against
the fact that berta was killed is very
clear to us in the human rights
community that if berta could be killed
with impunity
any of us could be killed think
everyone saw this as as a test
would honduras be up to the challenge
of investigating this murder in a
professional way
and taking it wherever it might lead
or would this notion of impunity carry
the day
from the beginning it seemed like the
police
were wanting to classify this as a crime
of
passion so they were looking at gustavo
castro as a person of interest
he had been in the house with her
he's been shot twice the mexican
ambassador tried to get him out of
honduras
he's now been taken again back to la
esperanza where
he was shot and she was assassinated
[Music]
i thought this was a classic way to try
and defect from
the real perpetrators particularly when
a woman is the victim
that they think that a kind of passion
is something that people will swallow
says
were really instrumental in trying to
push the police
into looking at the company desa they
reached out to other activists around
the world
for people to spread the word about what
had happened
i'm calling on the honduran government
to conduct a thorough
and transparent investigation into the
tragic
murder of berta caceres it doesn't look
like they're going to get
justice or proper investigations unless
outside protest really puts pressure on
the honduran government
[Music]
i think a lot of media attention all
over the world put pressure on the
honduran estate to
act responsibly and to do a genuine
[Music]
investigation
[Music]
[Music]
gustavo was finally allowed to leave and
essentially his name was cleared
and the focus of the investigation now
turned
directly towards desa
the police began analyzing phone data
so they looked at the cell phone towers
closest to berta's house
and found the phones that were active in
the area at the time of the murder
and so they began putting the pieces
together
on may 2 2016 police launched
a series of raids early in the morning
and they arrested
several people that they alleged were
involved in the murder
and these included alleged hitman
mariano diaz who was accused of being a
middleman
and douglas bustillo who was a former
security chief
for desa really the most important thing
that came of those raids
was what the police were able to collect
the cell phones
of the people who were arrested they
were able to retrieve
thousands and thousands of text messages
that became very critical
to reconstruct what happened in this
murder
i received a call from a colleague and i
was
asked to participate in in the
investigation
i was told that the family didn't
trust honduran authorities and that they
wanted an independent
investigation of the murder jose
the public prosecutor had access to
really a
treasure trove of digital data and they
gave us access to a small fraction
and we used that to identify
the parameters of the murder plot
[Music]
so verto was killed on march 2nd 2016.
on february 6 a month before her death
we can see in the text
probably the first attempt on berta's
life
this man named henry hernandez is sent
to the town of la esperanza
where berta was and he's supposed to be
met there
by mariano diaz an active member of the
military
we know that because mariano diaz's
phone had been
tapped because he was being investigated
for involvement in drug
trafficking and the transcripts of the
of those wiretaps demonstrate that
mariano
diaz is going to get hernandez a gun
at the same time mariano diaz is in
conversation with douglas bustillo
former head of security of thessa
douglas bustillo is asking mariano diaz
questions like have you gotten on the
bus
are you there yet
[Music]
later douglas bustillo texts
david castillo the president of the
company desa
and tells him mission aborted
so that mission was abandoned because
berta was not alone she her family was
visiting her
and so there wasn't really an
opportunity to
execute the plan
additionally when the investigators were
looking into duklis bustillo's phone
they found images of berta on it and
also
pictures that he'd taken of her house so
they believe he was
essentially stalking berta
[Music]
and then later around the time of the
murder
they saw that douglas bustillo was in
contact with the hitmen
so the investigators were able to make
that link
from the hitman through the middleman
through douglas bustillo
to the executives at desa to kind of
piece together
what they describe as this long-running
corporate conspiracy
to try to kill berta and so the
investigation
really led to the ceo of desa
david castillo
so david castillo was taken into custody
in
march of 2018. i visited castillo
early in 2020 and he was being held at a
military prison
just outside of tegucigalpa and so i was
able to sit down with him
in his cell and conduct a couple of
interviews with him
i did not participate in the murder of
berta caceres
there is no evidence whatsoever that
could link me to the killing of berta
david castillo becomes involved in desa
when he is still a member of the
military
he's integral to establishing
founding desa and we were particularly
interested
in his background as a military
intelligence officer so david
essentially says that the prosecutors
have totally misinterpreted these texts
that for example whenever there was a
mission that was aborted that they talk
about it being
a mission to kill berta he says no that
it was something completely different
and they've twisted the meaning to
implicate him
it had to do with a solar power plant
[Music]
so the mission important was like i am
not going to travel
to do the reconnaissance to the solar
uh project anymore
so one of david's main points
is he insists that he and berto were
actually good friends
i visited berta in la esperanza
multiple times and she also visited me
in tagucigalpa we begin
more of a friendly relationship in which
we don't discuss the project
so much and we we had a good time like
friends
he has text messages that his defense
has pulled from his phone between him
and berta
and many of these messages do indicate a
friendship
she was very suspicious of
david castillo and his motives
that doesn't mean that she did not
regard it as strategic
to have a relationship with him
it is
what we can also see is that he is
contacting berta
having conversations with her obtaining
information about her whereabouts
and her activities and then funneling
that
information to the company executives
and employees
how i interpret this dynamic is is quite
typical
of a military intelligence officer it's
using berta as human intelligence to
inform
how the company wants to handle
opposition to the dam project
berta was my friend it could not burn my
mind to do any harm
not only to berta to any human being i
could not believe how
evidence was manufactured that it would
lead to an accusation
it's unjust what i'm going through
i think it's fair to say that in
honduras people have been able to get
away with murder
the often quoted statistic is that
only about three percent of murders in
honduras
were solved so i think if you had asked
people
on that terrible morning when berta
caceres whispered
if they thought that people would be
held to account
for this crime i think most people would
have said no
now the question of course is is that
the ultimate chain
of command for for the murder or not
[Music]
so this investigation started with the
hitmen
essentially the people who pulled the
trigger it went to
david castillo the ceo in that executive
level
and now the casares family is sort of
testing
this concept to see how far you can
extend this
so now they're going after actually the
investors
in the dam project
i think it's far too easy for investors
to separate themselves from the impacts
of their money which is usually in
the global south you know it's their
money which is facilitating
and being used to carry out the projects
which are linked to so many of these
cases
of attacks and killings of activists
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
supporters and her family came up with a
slogan almost immediately after she was
murdered
and it's translated berta wasn't killed
she multiplied
that's the message that they take from
this
that even though her killers tried to
silence her
her voice is louder now than it had ever
been during her life
tiempo
you